Israeli forces entered the Palestinian
town of Janine after an intelligence
tip-off that a wanted terrorist was
hiding there
they surrounded a building and a gun
battle broke out when the militants
refused to surrender
the Israeli soldiers killed the gunman
suspected of shooting dead two Israeli
Brothers in the Palestinian town of
hawara 10 days ago
the incident led to Violent rights in
the town and renewed tensions in the
west Banks
foreign
last night Israeli settlers attacked
hawara again they threw rocks at Shops
and cars including one with a young
Palestinian family inside
[Applause]
[Music]
a mobile phone video doing the rounds on
social media channels shows Israeli
soldiers dancing with the settlers
nearby Israeli military has not
commented on it
Palestinian residents have now set up a
nightly neighborhood watch to try and
prevent further attacks
Israeli soldiers are still patrolling
the town but in fewer numbers
and Palestinians we spoke to said they
don't believe that they are being
protected by the military
do you feel safe here at the moment
actually
all people around seven o'clock all
people come and start the closing we ask
them why we are closing let's not save
here
the Muslim holy month of Ramadan is now
just two weeks away this year it again
coincides with the Jewish Festival of
Passover there is a growing fear that it
will be a particularly violent period
here and nothing has happened as yet to
avoid that
Alistair bunkel Sky News in the West
Bank